una nueva variante fue hallada en
sudáfrica los científicos advierten que
tiene el doble de nuevas mutaciones que
la variante delta por lo que han
alertado sobre su alta transmisibilidad
una cosa que sabemos acerca de las
variantes es que no sólo necesitan
emerger también necesitan normalmente
ser amplificadas por eventos de súper
propagación y en eso es en lo que en
este momento tenemos que concentrarnos
las autoridades aseguraron que esa
podría ser la razón por la que ha habido
un aumento drástico en los casos en el
territorio que pasó de tener un promedio
de 200 casos por día hasta alcanzar 1200
el miércoles
mientras el equipo científico estudia y
nos da más información a lo largo del
fin de semana estaremos más capacitados
pero por supuesto lo que estamos viendo
es que por la experiencia de los
aproximadamente veintiún meses casi que
podremos predecir cómo se va a mover de
crisis con tribus
identificada como la ve punto 1.1 529 la
variante tiene una proteína especular
sobre la que se han elaborado las
vacunas muy diferente a la del sar scott
2 lo que podría hacer que los sean menos
efectivos ante la amenaza el reino
unido- impuso restricciones de viajes
desde sudáfrica y cinco países africanos
namibia botsuana zimbabue lesoto y
suazilandia nuestros científicos están
profundamente preocupados por esta
variante estoy preocupado por supuesto y
esa es una de las razones por la que
hemos tomado esa medida hoy el equipo
técnico de la organización mundial de la
salud se reúne este viernes para evaluar
los alcances de la nueva variante